how's it going welcome to happy lab it's
been a while let's play seeing well
let's see what this month has to offer
when it comes to some good old-fashioned
happy
alright I'm Kirby hey how you doing
buddy hips II don't carry so many
speakers that could be dangerous
something bad might happen
the neon make a kind of minima alright
I'll play that one I have it go you love
[ __ ] stop calling me that
no that's your real name you little [ __ ]
that's what I named you your mom didn't
approve of it but your mom in here right
ah [ __ ] what is it dad shut up okay ah
[ __ ] I got me ah feels good though jet
pack a pro okay wait wait babe hey I can
see my insides I'm not beautiful on the
inside my mom lied frontflips some say I
sit here on my own free will
others say I'm stuck because my anus
ah finally I've been holding in that
fart for a long time not ECC challenge
okay hey that's great what do you mean
not easy that was [ __ ] easy hi when
welcome you dirty dirty peasants now
first of all for this meeting I would
just like to say you're all died I'm
just kidding of course yes your
Christmas bonus [ __ ] damn it that was
so lame Oh another Hulk smash I love
those grab the log if you want to murder
I don't wanna murder I'm so sorry
matrix hey what a minute
what a Malone do something now let
watermelon saves everyone not today mr.
spear warning Malone the credit greatest
water man up he's still like he's still
like okay rope soccer what the [ __ ] is
that there we go
boom [ __ ] so close but that doesn't
mean we can't have fun a baby come here
baby
let me massage that sweet sweet butt of
yours oh it's like a bongo drum isn't it
uh oh I'm so sorry what's your name
Jerry Jerry Jerry what's your name I
mean do you like weird positions Jerry
look at this son no hands no hands shut
up
no hands like a nice [ __ ] yeah let's go
buddy just you and me now bye
woohoo oh god what are we doing okay
then
don't copy me your piece of [ __ ] stupid
stop stop I do uh
suck my ass senpai suck it
okay this exchangers oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
please don't kill me kill my son please
ah thanks oh oh sorry sir
alright front flip hey I have a new hat
wonderful run oh my god damn it I'm
gonna use us to shoot oh you're the last
year she'll ever seen in my life
you're disgrace to this family go it's
time to make me proud
hmm I can smell my anus strawberry mmm
strawberry flavor no surprises here I
guess
Oh God Oh God hey I did it all right
cool wrong answer
what does that even mean hey what's this
21 I'll use this share as a shield cheap
IKEA shields hey I did it
hey that way okay that's a bad enough
happy wheels you're like if you don't
watching but I really appreciate it
subscribe to come for birth today and as
always thank you guys for watching stay
awesome bro